[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل الزوايا هو من
شمائل
المثمر مع السعوديه في مختلف المجالات
وتطلعه لحضور قمم الرياض
[موسيقى]
كيفك
انقلاب من اقصى اليمين كانت ستبدا
بالبرلمان وموسكو تن في تطورتها
وفي جمباز روسيا صادرت حقولا بضع في مساحه
نيويورك لتامين نفوذ عالميا واحاله
المشتكين لقانونها
تتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
قصد تتهم ترامب بخزانها وتامل العكس من
بيضنا وتشدد منفذه تفجير اسطنبول خرجت من
مناطق تحتلها تركيا
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الصينيه انه سيبحث مع العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان وولي عهده الامير
محمد بن سلمان التعاون الثنائي والقضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه الرئيس الصينيه اكد ان
تعاون العمل مع السعوديه اسفر عن نتائج
مثمره في المجله كافه مشيرا الى وجود ثقه
استراتيجيه متبادله مع السعوديه وبشكل
مستمر الرئيس الصيني الذي وصل الى الرياض
في وقت سابقا اليوم شددا على ان الصين
تربطها مع السعوديه
لحضور القمه الصينيه العربيه الاولى
والقمه الصينيه الخليجيه الاولى
[موسيقى]
هذا واكد الامير فيصل بن فرحان وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه انا استضافه الرياض
للقمه الثالثه
العزمه لتعزيز العلاقات مع الصيني كما
اشار وزير الخارجيه السعودي الى ان
العلاقات مع الصين استراتيجيه في ظل
التطورات على ساحه الدوليه
فيصل بن فرحان الى ان العلاقات الاقتصاديه
مع الصينه تسير بخطوات متسارعه فيما اضاف
وزير الخارجيه السعودي الى تطلع المملكه
للعمل مع الصين والدول الخليجيه والعربيه
خلال قمم الرياض
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه التي بنيت بين
السعوديه والصين على مدى عقود دعامه
اساسيه بني عليها تعاون اقتصادي مشترك
وتبادلات تجاريه واستثمارات لتصبح الصين
في السنوات الاخيره الشركه التجاريه
الاولى للمملكه
[موسيقى]
ارقام بالمليارات وحصص وزنا عززت سلما
الاستثمارات والتبادل التجاري بين الرياض
وبكينا فالصين تحولت لشركه تجاريا اول
للسعوديه في السنوات الخمس الاخيره مشكله
الوجه الاولى لصادرات المملكه ووالداتها
منذ عام 2018 حيث بلغ حجم التجاره بين
البلدين العام الماضي اكثر من 300 مليار
رياله اي بزياده قدرها 39% عن عام 2020
وفاق اجمالي حجم الصادرات السعوديه للصين
290 مليار ريال منها صادرات غير نفطيه
بقيمه واحد واربعين ملياراريال في ميزان
الذهب الاسود تميل الكفه السعوديه اكبر
مصدر للنفط الا بكينا لا سيما مع ارتفاع
الواردات الصينيه من السعوديه بنسبه ثلاثه
فاصل واحد في المئه مقارنه بعام 2020 اما
قيمه استثمارات المملكه في الصين فتصل الى
ثمانيه سيارات و600 مليون ريال ما وضعها
بالمرتبه الثانيه عشره في ترتيب الدول
المستثمره هناك حتى نهايه عام 2019 في
المقابل تستحوذ السعوديه على اكثر من 20%
من استثمارات الصين في العالم العربي
بنهايه العام الماضي اي ما قيمته 39 مليار
دولار وفي هذا الاطار وضعت شركه صينيه عدى
بينها تشينغ كونغ حجر الاساسي لمصانع
بمناطق سعوديه عده فيما تمثل شركات اخرى
كشركه ينبع ارامكو سينو باك للتكرير
نموذجا للشركات الاستثماريه المتزايده بين
البلدين مشروع لزياده التعاون النووي
وصندوق تمويل المشترك وعضويه تكتلات
الاقتصاديه دوليه وغيرها محطات على طريق
المواقمه بين رؤيه 2030 ومبادره الحزام
والطريق
وانضم الينا من الرياضه الدكتور فواز
العلمي الخبير في التجاره العالميه اهلا
بك معنا الليله الدكتور فواز يعني زياره
هامه واستثنائيه للرئيس الصيني الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وقمم خليجيه عربيه باي عين ينظر الرئيس
الصيني الى هذه القمم ما الذي يريده على
الصعيد الاقتصادي والسياسي
لكم
التوجه نحو الصين
ليس مشروع عن سياسيا حيث العلاقات مع
الغرب والشرق ستبقى موجوده لكن العلاقه
المميزه مع الصين خاصه في المجالات
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه والاستثماريه
هي المركز الاساسي في هذه العلاقه
لناخذ الصين مثلا ينظر الصين الى المملكه
التاليه الصين هي اكبر دوله مصدره للسلع
في العالم اثنين الصين تحتوي على التقنيه
وعلى العماله الماهره لدرجه ان 600 مصنع
امريكي واوروبي حاليا مستثمرين في الصين
للحصول على المواد الاوليه وانصاف
الموصلات والغائفا الالكترونيه وغيرها
ثالثا
الصين هي اكبر دوله مستورده للنفط من
المملكه اكثر من جارتها وشقيقتها روسيا
وبالتالي لا شك ان العلاقه بين الصين
والمملكه ستكون علاقه مميزه تجاريا
واقتصاديا واستثماريا في المستقبل نعم اذا
الدكتور فواز يعني سمي لنا لو سمحت مجلات
اقتصاديه بعينها لها الاولويه بالتطوير
والعمل عليها بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والصين يعني فيها
لديها الاولويه للتطور
الى اليوم ارتفعت التجاره البينيه بين
الدولتين 29
للمملكه وماذا ستقدم المملكه للصين
المزايا النسبيه التنافسيه الموجوده لا
تصين هي التي ستحكم ما هي المشاريع
المستقبليه ولكن انا اعتقد اهم هو صناعه
الصناعه
السيارات وصناعه المواد الاوليه وسلاسل
الامداد التي ممكن الصين تنقلها الى
المملكه
ثانيا المملكه تستطيع الاستثمار في الصين
في مشاريع مثل
البتروكيميكال
وانتاج المواد الهيدروكربونيه الاخرى وهذا
حاصل حاليا لكن
عندما جاء الحزام او الطليق الصيني الذي
كان موجودا كان يمر من خلال 65 دوله اليوم
ارتفعت عدد الدول الى 132 دوله وبالتالي
التجاره البينيه
وتدعيم الاستثمارات المشتركه في المملكه
او في الصين سيؤدي الى زياده الصادرات
السعوديه الغير نفسيه وزيادات الصادرات
الصينيه غير النقديه بحكم كون المملكه
موجوده على اهم ثلاثه ممرات مائيه في
العالم وهي مضيق هرمز الخليج العربي
المندب وقناه السويس البحر الاحمر تمر من
خلالها 13% من التجاره العالميه وا 34% من
النفط العالمي ابقى معي دكتور فواز
مشاهدينا في ابريل عام 2021 كشف ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان عن ان
السعوديه تصنع او تصنع شركات استراتيجيه
للحفاظ على مصالحها وتعمل ايضا على تعزيز
التحالفاتها مع الشركائها في العالم
[موسيقى]
امريكيه كانت في الخمسينات تشكل 50% من
تصاد العالم اليوم حجم الاقتصاد امريكي
يشكل ما يقارب 20% من حجم الاقتصاد
العالمي وبداء العالم يستعيد توازنه بعد
الحرب العالميه الاولى والثانيه نعمل على
الحفاظ على شركات الاستراتيجيه مع شركائنا
في المنطقه واللي هم اهم شركاء لنا ابتداء
من دول الخليج والدول العربيه ودول الشرق
الاوسط كما ان نعمل على تعزيز التحالفاتنا
مع
شركائنا في انحاء العالميه بريطانيا فرنسا
اوروبا وغيرها من الدول كذلك نعمل على صنع
شركات جديده مع الجميع روسيا او الهند
الهند او الصين او امريكا اللاتينيه او
افريقيا او غيرها لمصالح المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بما لا يضر اي دوله همم اخرى في
العالم فاليوم الصين اعلنت ايضا استراتيجي
والهند كذلك استراتي وكذلك روسي شريف
تيجي ليرتحده الامريكيه نعزز مصالحنا مع
الجميع بما يخدمنا وبما يخدم همخدموا
المصالح الدوليه وفي الاخير كل دوله لها
الخيار ان استطاع الان نعمل معهم على
انجاز ما فيه خير للجميع كان بها ولا نصف
همم لنستطيع في الخيارات واسعه في العالم
يعني الواضح من كلام ولي العهد السعوديه
الامير محمد بن سلمان بانه هذه الزياره
وهذه الرؤيه السعوديه بالمستقبل الشركات
العالميه الاقتصاديه ليست وليده هذه
الزياره اذا انما هي نتيجه تراكم يعني
العلاقات والرؤيه المستقبليه للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
صحيح
سمو ولي العهد في الواقع وضع النقاط على
الحروف
المملكه
وجميع الدول الاخرى في العالم هي اعضاء في
منظمه التجاره العالميه وبالتالي تلتزم
باتفاقيات هذه المنظمه المهم الان كيف
نستفيد من الدول الاخرى ذات المزايا
التنافسيه
ونجعلها تستثمر في المملكه وكيف تستفيد
هذه الدول من المملكه
ونستجعلنا نستثمر عندها يعني مصالح مشتركه
في شراكه استراتيجيه اقتصاديه تجاريه
استثماريه
لا تمت بسرعه الى النواحي السياسيه البحته
وانما هي تقوم على المصالح المشتركه بين
بين المملكه والدول الاخرى الله يحيي
الدول الاخرى اليابان الهند كما تحدث سمو
الامير على هذه
بشان هذه الدول فنحن مفتوحين على جميع
انحاء العالم الذين يرغبون في المشاركه
والاستثمار
والتجاره
الاقتصابا مميزه
باكثر من مناسبه اوضحت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بانها لا تريد الانغماس باي
نزاعات او تحالفات سياسيه عالميه مع اعترف
بالطرف واكبر مثال على ذلك همم يعني
حياتها بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
هي اكدت باكثر من مره ايضا بانها سوق
منفتح على كل الاسواق والاقتصادات الى اي
مدى هذا الحياد السياسي جعلها ملاذا
اقتصاديا امنا للصين وغيرها من الدول
[موسيقى]
في اوروبا
تستطيع ان تتعامل مع جميع الدول دون ان
يكون هنالك افراط او تفريط في النواحي
السياسيه والدخول في المغادرات بين الدول
نحن نريد
بالوطن اولا ثم المواطن نقل التقنيه
المعرفه
والصناعه والتجاره والاقتصاد هو هدفنا
الاول في هذه الشركات الاستراتيجيه ولذلك
سميت بالشركات الاستراتيجيه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك اذا الدكتور فواز
الاعلامي الخبير في التجاره العالمي على
اراك شكرا
[موسيقى]
شبح هو المانيا النازيه يحاول العوده على
انقاذ المانيا الاتحاديه هذا هو ملخص يوم
عاصف في احد اكبر قناع الديمقراطيه في
اوروبا
من رجال الشرطه داهموا مواقع في 11 من اصل
16 ولايه ما عكس انتشار الخليه المعنيه
بالمداهمات
المعتقللون اغلبهم المان اللافت ان من
بينهم قاديه كانت نائبه سابقه عن حزب
البديل من اجل المانيا المنتمي لاقصى
اليمين كما كان لافتا وجود ثلاثه اجانب
احدهم روسي الجنسيه وسط حديث غير مؤكد عن
اتصالات جرت مع مسؤولين رؤوس كما تم توقيف
شخصين خارج البلاد احدهما في النمسا
والاخر في ايطاليا لكن الاهم في كلام
الادعاء الالماني ان الخليه كانوا يعلمون
انه لا يمكنهم السيطره على الحكم من دون
عمل مسلح وان هدفهم الاول على ما يبدو كان
البرلمان الالماني
[موسيقى]
منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
والانقلابات العسكريه لا تعرف طريقا الى
اوروبا
لتاتي نهايه هذا العام وسلطات الالمانيه
تلقي القبض على عده اشخاص في مداهمات شملت
انحاء البلاد يشتبه بتامرهم للاطاحه
بالحكومه حيث صنف الادعاء الالماني تلك
المحاوله بالانقلاب على السلطه وان
المعتقلين يعتقد انهم شكلوا العام الماضي
منظمه ارهابيه بهدف قلب نظام الدوله
الحالي في المانيا واستبداله بنظام خاص
بهم فيما تشير تقارير المانيه الى ان
مجموعه من الشخصيات العسكريه السابقه
اليمنيه خطاطه الاقتحام مبنى البرلمان
والاستيلاء على السلطه
الاف شرطي نفذ عمليات تفتيش في 130 موقعا
داخل 11 من اصل نشره ولايه المانيه اسفرت
عن اعتقال 25 شخصا من افراد مجموعه يمنيه
ارهابيه القبض طال ايضا مواطنين روسا
الامر الذي دفع سفاره الروسيه في برلين
بالمصارعه الى نفي علاقتها مع هذه
المجموعه
موسكو لم تكتفي بنفي سفارتها بلتبع الامر
تصريحات الكرمل التي اعلنت ان المداهمات
الجاريه في المانيا شان داخليه والا علاقه
لروسيا بها
المداهمات وهي عمليه لمكافحه الارهاب
المشتبه بهم ربما خط طول شنه هجمات مسلحات
تستهدف مؤسسات الدوله
مداهمات اعتقالات واسلحه ضبطت مع
المعتقلين يتم استخدامها في الجيش
الالماني في ما تفيد تقارير المانيه ان
عسكريين السابقين هم ايضا جزء مهم من
مؤامره الانق هادئه وبينهم جنود نخبه
سابقون من الوحدات الخاصه
زرقاء اللون في مجلس الشيوخ
وديمقراطيون والجمهوريون من مناهري ترامب
يتشاركنا الفرحه
[موسيقى]
الجزر
موطن الحضارات العريقه
باسرارها العتيقه اساطير مضت منذ الاف
السنين
لكننا نعيش الان عصرا جديدا
لنسرد قصه جديده
الافات
جزيره بكر في البحر الاحمر بمياه الصافيه
تنسجم فيها الفخامه مع الطبيعه
وتساهم في حبها وكل لحظه فيها تجذب الهاما
جديدا
ليكشف النقابه عن عالم جديد
جزيره
ستكون فيها انت بطل قصتك
كن جزءا من الاسطوره سندريلا
[موسيقى]
غداء عمر
في هذه الاوقات على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
يا سيدي على لمه اهل الحجاز لقمه منتو على
سفرتهم ولا الحنين تحت غيوم الجنوب وسط
جبالها والله على صحن جريش اجمعنا في نجد
الاحباب
[موسيقى]
الشرقيه
وبهارات ثري دي يا بعد حيي ماخذه من ريح
الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي طعام المميز
حاضر معنا فيك الجمعاتنا الحلوه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد رجح الرئيس ان تكون
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
طويله الامل
خطر التهديد بوقوع حرب النوويه بات مرتفعا
مشيرا الى ان 150 الف جندي من الاحتياط
التحقوا بما يدين القتال في اوكرانيا
معتبرا الا حاجه حاليا لعمليه تعبئه
عسكريه جديده
لا تمتلك اسلحه تكتيكيه نوويه خارجه روسيا
على عكس الولايات المتحده
سيطرته على الارض غير ممكنه من دون
السيطره على ثرواتها لذا سارع بعض من كبار
المتنفذين الروس مع بدء الحرف في اوكرانيا
بالاسلاء على الاراضي الزراعيه الاوكرانيه
نتحدث هنا عن الاوليغارشيين المقربين من
الكرملين الذين سيطروا على اراضي تفوق
مساحتها ضعف مساحه مدينه نيويورك كما انها
من اكثر الاراضي خصوبه في العالم تحقيق
مطول لويس رجون الامريكيه قال فيه ان
المسؤولين الروس استولوا على اكثر من
400,000 فنانه من المناطق الاخرانيه وان
الجيش لم يضع يده على هذه المناطق هذه
الاراضي باتت تحت سطوه اليكساندر كاشف
وزير الزراعه الروسي السابق ومن نصيب شركه
العائليه اوكرانيا قالت ان شركه ادرو
كونتلاكس الروسيه المملوكه للكات بدات منذ
اشهر التسلل بهدوء الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
مدعومه بالجيش لجني فوائد اقتصاديه من
اوكرانيا واستخدام هذه المكاسب للمساعده
في السيطره على المنطقه باكمله المخابرات
الاوكرانيه قالت ان الاستلاء على الاراضي
الزراعيه بدا بانشاء ادارات مدنيه محليه
في الاجزاء الخاضعه للسيطره الروسيه شرق
اوكرانيا تحديدا في لوغانس ودونات
المسؤولون الانفصاليون الموالون لروسيا
باشروا بعد ذلك زياره المزارعين
الاوكرانيين في مواكب مسلحه لاصال رساله
مفادها انهم باتوا المسيطرين على المنطقه
اول من فقدوا اراضيهم هم الملاك الذين
خدموا في الخدمه العسكريه او المدنيه في
اوكرانيا اضافه للملاك الذين يعيشون خارج
المنطقه في بعض الحالات تعرض المزارعون
جديد اذا لم يستمر في العمل كما اجبر ملاك
اخرون على اعاده كتابه العقود بما في ذلك
سندات الملكيه لتتوافق مع القانون الروسي
وليس الاخرى
جون قالت ان حالات موفقه اظهرت ان مالكي
الاراضي سمح لهم بالاحتفاظ
بمزرعهم لكن العقود الجديده نصت على ان
يذهب سبعون في المئه من المحصول الى روسيا
او سلطات دونات
مصادره الاراضي شرق اوكرانيا تهدد بوضع
جزء كبير من احد اكبر محاصيل الحبوب في
العالم تحت السيطره الروسيه ومن المتوقع
ان تؤدي هذه الخطوات الى زياده النفوذ
الاقتصاديه العالمي لموسكو خاصه في الدول
الناميه التي تعتمد على انتاج الحبوب
الاوكرانيه والروسيه للح على الغذاء شركه
اجرو كومبلكس الروسيه تقوم بالفعل بزراعه
جزء كبير من الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفقا
للمخابرات واصحاب المزارع الاوكرانيين
فالشركه تشارك في ضمان سيطره روسيا على
الانتاج الزراعي ومنذ يوليو
ظهر اسطول من مركبات الحصاد الروسيه على
ارض شركه اوكرانيه لتبدا في حصاد محصول
القمح الذي زرعته سابقا شركه اجرون
الاوكرانيه من جانبها قالت الشركه الروسيه
ان شركتين اوكرانيتين تخلتا عن مشاريعهما
وموظفهما وان اجركمبلكس دفعت ملايين
الدولارات كعويد مقابل اصول الشركه وهو ما
تنفيه الشركاتان الاوكرانيتان ومزارعون
اوكرانيون تم الاستلاء على اراضيهم الكلام
رد على ملف التعويضات بالقول ان مناطق شرق
اوكرانيا هي الان جزء روسيا وان اصحاب
المزارع يمكنهم المطالبه بحقوقهم وفقا
لقوانين روسيا
[موسيقى]
غرات وقصف لعشره ايام استهدف مناطق واسعه
في شمال العراق وسوريا بدا بوقت الحساب
كما اسمته وزاره الدفاع التركيه مع
اعلانها عمليه المخلب السيف في العشرين من
نوفمبر لكن التراجع النسبيا للقصف التركيه
المكثف له حذاء الاسبوع الماضي لكن عمليه
عسكريه بريه وشيكه يصفها الاتراك بالهجوم
الذي مهما اعطي امهالا لانه لا مفر منه
بشكل نهائي لتبرز التساؤلات حول من يعطي
الضوء الاخضر لانقره في شن عملياتها على
تلك الاراضي او بشكل ادى ادق من يؤثر على
قراراتها حينما شنت تركيا هذه العمليه
كانت ذراعتها تفجير اسطنبول الدموي في
منتصف في نوفمبر والمخلب السيف ما هو الا
التكشير عن انياب تركيا طب اي شيء يمسه
امنا 85 مليون مدني وردا على ما قسمته
هجوما غادرا كانت قد اتهمت في ذاك
الاعتداء كل من حزب العمال الكردستاني
والقوات الكرديه في سوريا بالوقوف خلفه
اشتد القصف على الشمال السوري في الربع
الاخير من نوفمبر وشمله عده مناطق ابرزها
عين العرب كوباني
والمالكيه هنا اتت امريكا وعبرت عن
مخاوفها على لسان وزاره الدفاع البنتاجون
وقالت ان الضربات الجويه هددت سلامه
الامريكيين الموجودين هناك وكذلك ابدت
قلقها حول تقويض القضاء على داعش اليوم
حضر المبعوث الامريكي لشؤون شمال شرق
سوريا
على تلك المناطق قائلا ان واشنطن لم تمنح
انقره الضوء الاخضر لذلك
[موسيقى]
اذا هو تهديد وانا
لم يكن الاول سبقه اقتحام قبل ثلاثه اعوام
يتزمن مع خشيه من طعنه في ظهر قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه فعلى حد تعبير قائدهم مظلوم
عبد فانهم قلقون من خذلان قد يكسر امال
قصد بامريكا كما فعلت سابقا في عهد الرئيس
السابق دون ترامب عام 2019 حينما التزم
الصمت ولم يقف ضد تركيا عبر عبدي ايضا عن
مخاوفه فحكايه زعزعت الثقه بين الغرب
واشنطن بالنسبه للاكراد لم تكن مره ولا
مرتين بل سبع مرات خلال قرن باكمله لكنهم
مع اداره الرئيس جو باردن يلتمسون املا
ولو كان ضئي لنا في ادارهته بوعودها
وبالتزاماتها والا تسمح لتركيا بالقيام
باي عمليه قد يكون الضغط عليها سواء من
روسيا او امريكا
بالتراجع الملحوظ عن القذف لاسيما وان
انقره قامت بخروقات لتفاهمات كانت اجرتها
معهما وعن محاربه داعش قال عبدي انهم لم
يتخلوا عن ذلك مع التحالف لكنه منشغلون
بالتصدي بسبب الاوضاع الامنيه وبما انه
تحسن قليلا عاده التعاون المشتركه وشدد
عبدي في حواره على ان علاقه للاكراد
بتفجير اسطنبول كما زعموا بانهم يملكون
ادله لم يقبلوا ان يكشفوها لاحد فهذه
عاداتهم لا يحبون التعاون مع احدا ولم
يعطوا اي معلومه حقيقيه تدين الاكراد حتى
للجانب الامريكي فهم على حد التعبير عبدي
يعطونا المعلومات عبر طرف واحد الا وهو
الاعلام مضيفا انهم جمعوا كل التصريحات
الاعلاميه وبشر وتحقيقات تبرئهم من كل ذلك
فبحسبي ما توصلوا اليه الاشخاص الذين
قدموا الاتراك واسمائهم ق منهم من مدن
كانت مع داعش والبنت التي نفذت العمليه
قامت قبلها بفتره قصيره بزيارات عده الى
عفرينا حيث يقيم اخوها وعمها وعدد من
افراد عائلتها هنا مربط الفرس في عفرين
ليست تحت سيطره الاكراد وانما الاتراك
بقياده ما يسمى الجيش الوطني لذا واجه عبد
التهاما ضنيا لتركيا فان تفجير اسطنبول له
علاقه بالمناطق المحتله من قبلهم حيث ان
قسما من المتفجرات اتى من جرابلس
[موسيقى]
اذا خبراء وسياسيون اشارو الى ان
المفاوضات التي تجريها انقره مع واشنطن
وموسكو حاليا ليست لوقف العمليه وانما
للحصول على المزيد من الضمانات لحمايه
الحدود التركيه ما يعني ان تركيا قد لا
تابه بموافقه امريكا في حين كان لمحللين
اخرين راي مختلف معتبرين ان التهديدات
التركيه تطلق منذ اشهر لكنها في الواقع لن
تنفذ باي شيء على الارض بل انها تصعد
لهجتها لترفع سقف مطالبها ثم تتراجع ولم
تتلقى تركيا حتى الان ايرد من الولايات
المتحده لكن بعض المصادر المحت الى ان
واشنطن اقترحت اعاده هيكلت قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه ومنح دور اكبر للمكون العربي
في اداره منبج وتلرفعه عين العرب اما جانب
الروسي الى حد ما يبدو مع شروط تركيا لكنه
وضع شروطا تتعلق بالملف الاوكراني مقابل
التقديم تنازلات ميدانيه وسياسيه في سوريا
حيث عرضت موسكو رفع الغطاء عن منطقه
الشهباء في ريف حلب وعين العرب لتسهيل
دخول القوات التركيه اليهما لتبقى
التوقعات ترجح ان تركيا قد تطلق عمليات
محدوده مع اصرار على وجود منطقه امنه على
طول الحدود بينهما او بينها وبين سوريا
[موسيقى]
وبالعوده الى موضوع احباط محاوله الانقلاب
من اقصى اليمين التي حصلت في المانيا
اليوم ينضم الينا من العاصمه برلين عبر
زوم جيهان عمر النائب البرلماني اهلا بك
سيد عمر يعني
ان تكشف عمليه بهذا الحجم وبهذه الضخامه
في دوله مثل المانيا بعد ان وصلت لهذه
المرحله المتقدمه هل هو نجاح امل فشل
مساء الخير لك يا ولد المشاهدين في
الحقيقه اليوم استطعت المانيا على هول هذه
العمليه هذه العمليه الامنيه
الاستخباراتيه المشتركه التي كانت نتيجه
لمراقبه استمرت لشهور عديده العديد من
الشخصيات
والمنظمات اليمنيه المتطرفه على راسها
منظمه الجماعات اي هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين لا
يعترفون بالجمهوريه الاتحاديه الالمانيه
وهو اعاده المانيا الى العصر الامبراطوريه
وعددهم يتراوح عدد افراد هذه المجموعه بين
20,000 الى 25,000 فرده لكن ليس جميعهم
مسلحون الاشخاص الذين تم اعتقالهم هم 25
شخصا والاضافه الى ان هناك اسماء اخرى يتم
البحث عنها والمداهمات مستمره منذ الساعه
السادسه صباحا في 11 نقاط المانيه اضافه
الى ان هناك اعتقالات حصلت في النساء
همم الشيء الذي همم يثير الانتباه هو ان
هناك شخصيات موجوده في اماكن حساسه في
اجهزه الدوله هناك قاضيه المانيه كانت
سابقا عضوه في البرلمان الالماني ضمن هذا
التنظيم هناك شبكات لها تواصل داخل اجهزه
الامن والدوله وايضا الجيش الالماني
وهؤلاء كان يوفرون معلومات استخباراتيه
الدقيقه لهذه المجموعات المتطرفه لذلك
كانت هذه ضربه قاسمه لهذه المجموعات
ومخططات حقيقيه
حاول الاسم الروسي والتواصل مع مسؤولين
روس
منذ انطلاق حزب اليمين المتطرف حزب البديل
لاجل الالماني ودخوله الى البرلمانات
الالمانيه نشاه هذا الكذب في العمل 2013
وبدا بالدخول الى البرلمان المقاطعات الى
اضافه الى البرلمان الاتحاد منذ عام 2015
وهذا الحزب يتلقى دعما علانيا من القياده
الروسيه من الكريم
والسياسي وايضا المالي وهناك الشخصيات
وبرلمانيون من حزب البديل ذهبوا ولا
يزالون ايضا يذهبون في زيارات رسميه الى
الكريم وحتى بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا لا تزال الزيارات
غير متوقفه لذلك همم
الدعم الروسي لهذه الجماعات سوف يتبين
خلال الاسابيع المقبله الان بدات الاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه بالقاء القبض على هؤلاء
الشخصيات والكشف عن المخططاتهم ولكن في
الايام
سوف نشهد العديد من المعلومات التي توضح
لنا حيثيه هذه المجموعات وقدراتها
الحقيقيه
عمر النائب البرلماني شكرا
[موسيقى]
جزيلا
في كوريا الجنوبيه تريد ان تخرج عن نظام
حسنا لكن بنظام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الحزب الديمقراطي
الامريكي يحكم قبضته اكثر على مجلس الشيوخ
بعد ظهور نتائج ولايات جورج
الامريكيه صوت امس في انتخابات الاعاده
على المقعد الاخير في انتخابات التجديد
النصفي التنافس كان بين السنه
الديمقراطيه رافا
والجمهوريه في
سباقتين ونصف بين المتنافسين فوز وارنوب
منح الديمقراطيين مقعدهم الحادي والخمسين
في مجلس الشيوخ ما يعطيهم مزيدا من النفوذ
في المجلس الذي كان مقسوما
بالتناصف بين الحزبين لمده عامين النتيجه
توجد ايضا خيبه الامل على الجانب الجمهوري
الذي توقع موجه حمراء في الانتخابات
النصفيه لكنهم فاشلوا في السعاده مجلس
الشيوخ ونجحه بالحصول على اغلبيه في مجلس
النواب
فواكه
[تصفيق]
الملك سلمان في هذه الاثناء جلسه مجلس
الوزراء السعودي لاقرار الميزانيه العامه
للدوله
الملك سلمان بعد قليل فورا
اعاده انتخابات الديمقراطيه حسب نيويورك
تايمز اظهرت مجددا اهميه ولايه جورجيا في
الانتخابات على اختلافها برلمانيه كانت
رئاسيه الصحيفه اعتبرت ان انتخابات
الاعاده في جورجيا بالامكان
قالت انها الدروس المستفاده من الانتخابات
رغم الفضاء المختلفه التي لاحقت هيرشي
الوكر الصحيفه اضافت ان ترامب يتحمل جزءا
من اللوم لاختياره لوكر في وقت يواجه فيه
همم هو شخصيا ملاحقه قضائيه متعلقه
بالتهرب الضريبيه ترامب نفسه اصبح اول
مرشح جمهوري يخسر ولايه جورجيا خلال
انتخابات رئاسيه منذ 28 عاما في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاخيره قبل عامين
النقطه الثانيه هي ان جزءا من الجمهوريين
بداوا الابتعاد عن ترامب خاصه وانا اكثر
من 200,000 جمهوري صوتوا لحاكم الولايه
الجمهوري الشهر الماضي لم يصوتوا لمرشح
ترامب لمجلس الشيوخ في انتخابات الاعاده
نيورك تايمز قالت ان من بين الدروس
المستفاده ان جورجيا ستكون مره اخرى نقطه
ساخنه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد عامين
وان الديمقراطيين سيحظون بدعم كبير تحديدا
في المدن الكبرى مثل اتلانتا عاصمه
الولايه وان تمثل نحو 60% من القوه
الانتخابيه لها الدرس الرابع حسب ما قالت
نيويورك تايم انما ساعه الجمهوريين عبر
فرق قانون جديد مقيد للتصويت لم يجد نفعا
فالجمهوريون شددوا شروط المطلوبه لاقتراع
المواطنين في مسعى الاستعاذه مقعد مجلس
الشيوخ هذا العام لكنه جهودهم اتت بنتائج
عكسيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نتقل الان الى الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله عام 2024 وجدل على الجانب
الديمقراطي حول ما اذا كان يتعين على
الرئيس الترشح ام لا مجله نيوز ويك نقلت
عن مساعد للرئيس الاسبق باراك اوباما
اقتراحا مفاده انا انصار اوباما يريدون
الى حد كبير رؤيه وجوه جديده على اللائحه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المخاوف بشكل اساسي
تتمحور حول عمر بايدن الذي تجاوز قبل ايام
80 عاما من عمره وانه سيكون في الثانيه
والثمانين حالا انتخابه لولايه ثانيه كانت
استطلاعات رائعه قبل الانتخابات النصفيه
بينت ان غالبيه الديمقراطيين ارادوا مرشحا
اخر غير بايضا لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بعد عمل
يبدا يعدد متزايد من اعضاء الحزب
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه اعتراضهم لترشيح
الرئيس الحالي جوبايدن في انتخابات
الرئاسه المرتقبه في 2024 لاسيما في ظل
تذمر الامريكيين من اداء الاقتصادي فيما
يقولوا اخرون ان الساكن البيت الابيض
سيكون قد تجاوز 80 من العمر وسط اسئله
تصار حول لياقته الصحيه حتى على مستوى
الحزب نفسه يبدو ان هناك بالفعل اعترافا
بالحاجه الى قياده جديده خاصه بعد النجاح
غير المتوقع لمرشحين في الانتخابات
النصفيه ضد مجموعه من المرشحين الجمهوريين
الضعفاء لذلك اعلنت رئيسه مجلس النواب
نانسي والاغلبيه في مجلس النواب جيمبر
الثاني 82 عاما مؤخرا انهما سيتنحيان عن
مناصبهما القياديه في الكونغرس القادم
لرفع مستوى مجموعه من الديمقراطيه من
الاصغر وعلى الر من نجاحه في تجنب موجه
حمراء تحت قبه الكونجرس كما توقع عدد من
المحللين والاستراتيجيين في الانتخابات
النصفيه ان اخر استطلاع عن الراي اظهر
رفضه 45% من الامريكيين لاداء الرئيس
العربيه استطلعت اراء بعض المواطنين
لديمقراطيين وسالناهم هل تؤيدون الترشح
بيضا في الانتخابات القادمه ام تفضلون
رؤيه وجه جديد متابعه
لايك وادي هيستون
وانا اعتقد انه اكثر اثاره للاعجاب من
رئيسنا السابق
لقد قام بعمل رائع كرئيس فهو يهتم بالبيئه
والموظفين والعمال لطالما فعل ذلك ولكنني
اتمنى لو كان اصغر عمرا قليلا
[موسيقى]
اتخاذ قرار بشان من سيرشحون كبديل
الانتخابات ضد ترامب فساد
هو بيقول
الرئيس
بدلا من الجمهوريين